as a solution architect i'm often
thinking about all my inputs and my
outputs that must occur within my
architecture but what if all that input
is actual paper documents
hello my name is jamil spain developer
advocate with ibm cloud and for all
those paper documents that you'll have
you have to think of a mass way that you
want to process all those
my topic for today is automation
document
processing so let's take a look at what
really this concerns here it's really
centered around one major principle here
is that you want to get all the data
inputted from these forms
and a lot of traditional workflows
actually encapsulate uh having or have
that process of having paper that needs
to be filled out scanned in and turned
in
and what's your major option to process
that human people human workers actually
have to read and input that data entry
into the system here
but the difference here with this
document processing is that we're going
to apply
ai machine learning
and a loco
no code solution
to allow you to
build machine models that actually learn
from a lot of these uh
the context of what your
the documents that you have coming into
the system and allow you to build some
workflow that interprets and what
happens next once you have have re
extracted all the data out from that so
what are the benefits of doing this why
would i want to invest a time to do this
well i just mentioned one earlier with
all these documents you must have manual
people that manually look at
and process this data and after hours
and hours of looking at the same
document we want to also
ensure well one thing that we're going
to ensure by doing it from an automated
perspective is making sure we have that
data accuracy
and for any any what it would kind of
replace or optimize is take your
people's time to do other tasks because
and eliminate all the errors
that can occur from
people just looking at the same document
immune name tasks of interpreting all
this information here so
let's bring a little more perspective to
this so now that we've kind of
set down the context of what we're
discussing let's get to the white board
over here to the right and kind of
figure out uh the light board over here
and figure out how does this kind of map
out here well we know that let me see if
i can do a person here they have a
document that they're going to always
put in and these can be multiples of
single or
we're talking you know to the thousands
and thousands let's think of it as a
doctor's office that has to process all
this paper to come in haven't quite
digitized their process yet but this is
one way they can still do their
traditional business and make that input
of data that they want to get off those
forms
to be digitized that workflow so when
you have these actual documents that are
coming in what you're going to actually
do is
i'm going to abbreviate here the
document processing cloud let's say
so that data is going to be coming in
now inside here we're going to make sure
that we make a model
that really studies the particular
information that's there we may be able
to classify some fields as personal data
pii data personal information
or public information or information
that's protected so we have that ability
there
and
its major job as that document comes
into making a model it's going to try to
interpret we can highlight the fields it
must be there to say you need to pull
this information off the page all right
it will try its best to kind of
interpret that as well and i can also
tell it to if information does not it's
not clear or it cannot interpret it
outright let that be a state that user
intuition is required where i must say i
agree this is what i it thinks it found
this is what i agree that it found but
the important thing here is the machine
learning
so as we start processing more and more
documents it gets to learn from all the
use cases
that it comes across and get smarter and
smarter get more and more efficient
from there but as you kind of go in the
output of that is going to be the data
that you want to extract and so whether
that integrates into other systems
through apis or some type of other
application that needs the data
you can now start to go and continue
processing and go
from there as well
so what we discovered today is document
processing having large amounts of paper
that you want to digitize
into and get that workflow to be
something you can speed up and really
meet the demand that processing needs to
occur today in our common event-driven
applications that we kind of go into so
this is a great discipline to get into
for your project if you have these
symptoms of documents that you want to
process i recommend you give document
processing a look thank you for your
time
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future
please like and subscribe